【はじめ唾を吐く】
【はじめの激しい咳】
ぴぇぁ！
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん クリスマスイブ
いかがお過ごしでしょうか
というわけで今年もクリスマスが
やって来たんですけども
【はじめ唾を吐く】
みなさん イルミネーション
見ましたか？
やっぱりこうクリスマスと言うと
キレイなイルミネーション
見に行くみたいな流れが
こう一般的にはあるんですけども
外は寒い 出たくない
カップルだらけ うぜえ
(拳ﾊﾟｧﾝ)
というわけで室内の中で
何とかイルミネーション作れねえかと
考えたんですけども
Aha!
室内のイルミネーションだと
どうしても外のあのキラキラの
イルミニ…ネーションには劣っちゃうんで
外には 勝てない…
だが 私は勝ちますよ
負けてらんねええ！
めちゃくちゃイルミネーション
買ってきました
10m
10m×2
10m×3  10m×4
10m×5  5m
10m×6
10m×7  10m×8  10m×9
10m×10
10m×11  10m×12
10m×13  10m×14
全部合わせて50m
200m分のイルミネーション
準備しました！
ハッハァァァーー！(狂気)
Merry Christmas
200m分のイルミネーション準備しました
フォォォォォォーーーーーゥ！(発狂)
【はじめ我に返る】
チッ(舌打ち)
外に出ても寂しいし寒いし
なんか悲しくなるんで
部屋の中でそこら辺の
イルミネーションよりも
もっとキレイなイルミネーション
この部屋で奏でられないかと思ったので
実際にやってみようと思います
ではいこう！
ひとりで
あぁぁーーー！
では早速やっていこうと思います
コンセントの量がすごくなると思ったので
先にたくさん電源タップを買ってきました
電源差すところが増えて
もうなんとか対応できるようには
しております
いや これ すごいぞ
室内では史上最強レベルに
イルミネーションが作れるんじゃねえか
っていうぐらい
ちょっとほんとに頑張りますね
それなりにいけますぞ これは
では早速 繋いでいこうと思います
えっ
おーこれすごいな マジで超長いな
【早送り中…】
1回ちょっとつけてみます
はっ はっ はっ はっ はっ
え え やばい！
あぁーー！
おっ 待って、思った以上に
クリスマスだ！
え まじやる気出てきた
ちょっと頑張ろ
え やばい！
やばい！
楽しい！
はい！わ！わ！わ！わ！わ！わ！
ちょっと 光らせるの
最後のお楽しみにしましょう
【早送り中…】
あぁーーぃ！(ライト落下)
たぶん 今ぐらいの量が
一番キレイだと思うんですよ
1回つけてみますか！
いきまーす
はい
おぉ！
あれ なんか 主張が激しいな
あはっ
いかがでしょうか(イケボ)
きっと 今ぐらいのイルミネーションが
一番キレイだと思うんですけども
多分 ここからちょっともう
キレイを超えていくのかな
っていう気がするんですけども
まだまだあるのでちょっと
どんどんつけていこうと思います
では
【早送り中…】
【JUDY AND MARY「そばかす」】
♪∼ 想い出は いつも キレイだけど
♪∼ それだけじゃ おなかがすくわ
【早送り中…】
(ﾊﾟｧﾝ!)
うわぁ！ はっ！
なんか これ あれなんすよね
なんか 開けたときすごい
なんか イルミネーションが
これ絡まってるんで
1回 振り回さないとダメなんすよ
(ﾊﾟﾝ! ﾊﾟｧﾝ!)
あぁっ！
(ﾊﾟﾝ!)
あっ！ はぁっ！
なんでこんな絡まってんだ
(ﾊﾟﾝ!ﾊﾟﾝ!)
あぁっ！
【早送り中…】
はい！ というわけで完成しました！
追加でけっこう購入したんで
まぁ大体300ｍってとこかな
300m分のイルミネーションをここにすべて
張りつくせました
はい というわけで
とりあえず1回点滅させてみましょう
では つけていきます！
こっちも！はい！
待って 待って 待って 待って
明るい 明るい 明るい！
やばい 超キレイです
めちゃくちゃ部屋の中が明るいし
色が幻想的なんすよ
すげえ 完全にクリスマスですね
いや めっちゃキレイだな おい
はい というわけで
部屋がキレイになったのは
分かったと思うんですけども
ここで 私はー…
オ モ ッ タ
イルミネーションって1粒1粒がとてもキレイ
で なんか、強いようでちょっと弱そうな光
でもめちゃくちゃたくさんの
イルミネーション
300m近くあるんですけども
今度イルミネーションをすべて
ひとかたまりの玉にすると
どんだけ明るくて美しいものになるのか
想像 絶するっすよ
ﾊｧｯｯ(狂気)
想像 絶するキレイさになると思うんですよ
キレイを1つにまとめると
多分めちゃくちゃキレイな玉が
できると思うので
あのー せっかく壁にはったんですけど
今からぜんぶ外して
ひとかたまりの玉にして
めちゃくちゃキレイな
イルミネーションボールを
作ってみようと思います
めんどくさい！
【早送り中…】
集まれ！ LED達よ！
今こそ力を1つに！
はい！
できました！
では早速
史上最強のイルミネーションライトの
光の強さを
見ていこうと思います！
聖なる夜に…
Merry Christmas
いきます！
【ED】♫∼
うわぁー
キレイだけど...
寂しいなぁー！
多分あれだ
多分これ電源落としたときの
悲しさがすげえやつだ
落としてみまーす
うわっ！
泣きそう